[Music]
like
they know one truth
time for the Jedi to end
happy Star Wars week continues everybody
so there's a whole bunch more trailer
Easter eggs that we got to break down
especially wills and especially the
audio stuff if you're new to the channel
I do Star Wars videos every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything but there
were a lot of audio Easter eggs there
were a lot of visual Easter eggs and we
have to talk about the Journal of the
Wills it is huge in this trailer and
it's going to be huge in the future of
Star Wars so the biggest thing first
everybody's talking about the audio
Easter eggs yes there's Obi one yes
there's Yoda yes there's Palpatine yes
there's Princess Leia yes there's Darth
Vader so they do this interesting thing
they're talking about balance in the
trailer the balance between the light in
the dark it's so much bigger than that
as Luke says but as they zoom in on Leia
it's from the left channel where you
here help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my
only hope then you hear Darth Vader
breathing from the right side channel
you hear obi-wan say seduced by the dark
side of the force
talking about Darth Vader but also hat
tip to kylo Ren seduced by the dark side
of the force
then as they zoom in on the Journal of
the Wills you hear Yoda's voice say
surrounds us and binds us the speech
from Empire Strikes Back in both
channels so they do this right side left
side you know light side dark side then
both combined so much bigger Luke thing
so they really want you to think about a
new definition of the force as they zoom
in on the Journal of the will'd and
that's what this symbol is it is you
look at this symbol here doesn't this
look a lot like the symbol of the Jedi
so the Wills of this mysterious race
that George Lucas envisioned when he was
writing the first draft of Star Wars it
was meant to be volume 1 Journal of the
Wills that was a new hope before they
changed things and turned it into
something different but now in more
recent years Star Wars has begun to
canonize the Journal of the Wills and
really interesting ways they show up
during rogue one the guardian of the
Wills did their to guard the temple but
the Wills are the people that predated
the Jedi they have a pre Jedi
understanding of the force so the book
itself is a much more complete
understanding of the force supposedly
making you much more powerful than a
Jedi or a Sith
which explains why kylo Ren and Snoke
are looking for it in addition to Luke
and when he says the Jedi Order needs to
end
what he's really talking about is that
they need to get back to the truth of
thing he's not saying that because
turned evil or because he hates the Jedi
he just feels like the Jedi were not
successful he never achieved his true
potential there's a lot of that they
were implying during Star Wars
Celebration this weekend the story of
what Luke did between the movies because
he was supposed to be this Jedi Crusader
taking down the rest of the Empire but
that never happened because when we got
to force awakens we find out that he
went off looking for the original Jedi
Temple looking for the Journal of the
Wills so a lot of people were wondering
is that was Benicio Del Toro's voice at
the end because it's kind of gruff and
low but you can actually see Luke's lips
moving in the background here so that is
him telling ray that it's time for the
Jedi Order to end but that's not because
he's gone bad maybe he's gone a little
crazy in his Hermitude array is probably
going to be very disappointed in that
the director Rian Johnson even confirmed
that he intended for the last Jedi to be
singular Luke was the last Jedi going to
look for the Journal of the Wills and he
says the Jedi need to end so we have so
many words tongue-in-cheek he's
confirming Luke is the last Jedi but
everybody else is going to be the first
of something new like raised character
and if kylo Ren survives maybe he'll
also become part of this new thing - so
how does range Lucas will be different
from like Luke's relationship with sales
odo well rain is not a teacher
Yoda and obi-wan are very much like
guiding stickers like the present Arabia
and an array I probably need to name in
over two years which turns up like this
freakin lightsaber that you have seen
and however long so so that in itself is
a big difference and then as things go a
lot I think there's a there's an
expectation there's always been an
expectation or Luke as soon as
potentially what you can do and what he
should do much like my brain so in that
sense they're kind of similar but
obviously the dynamic is change because
she's expecting something from him
and it remains to be seen with it you
know how he we asked about let's talk
about the symbolism of the posters
though red is a very big color in this
movie red and Star Wars is typically the
color of evil the color of the Sith so
it lets you know that these characters
are not in a good place they might not
leave the movie in a good place just
like the characters in Empire did it was
the darkest movie of the trilogy this
poster in the color tone of the trailer
lets you know that this is probably
going to be the darkest movie of this
trilogy but then you look at Rey she's
kind of like the blue light of hope
between Luke and kylo Ren from both a
very cynical views on their perspective
of the force Luke is an old man he's
like you know this isn't my story
anymore it's all about the new
characters it's all about the new way of
things finding out what the Journal of
the Wills might teach them about the
future of the force in the direction
that they should be taking and on the
other side of things kylo Ren is firmly
entrenched in his belief that Darth
Vader had the right idea and he's going
to bring that original vision to
fruition with the help of Supreme Leader
Snoke but the symbol that they're making
on the poster is the symbol on the
Journal of the Wills so whatever you
think might happen to these characters
the three of them are all about the
spiritual journey of the movie in the
idea that the wheels have they certainly
make it seem like somebody's going to
get their hands on the book but you see
a glove it doesn't look like an evil
person's glove because kylo Ren wears
black gloves so it at least seems like
Luke and Rey are going to get a peek in
there but I'm not expecting them to
answer all the questions in this movie
that's usually reserved for the final
movie and then like whatever story comes
next
but I am excited for this symbol to
start showing up on merchandise later
this year because everybody's wondering
what are they going to do to the Jedi
Order
the name Jedi is so important for Star
Wars merchandising not just the history
of Star Wars and the characters in the
movie Jedi will always be a big thing in
Star Wars but it almost seems like what
they're saying here is that there's
going to be some new thing maybe it'll
be called something different but if
they're turning everybody into something
different from the Jedi Order what are
they going to call it and what are they
going to put on all the merchandise
that's just such a crazy thought in real
life but we got some more answers on
some of the other things in the trailer
- so this salt planet that's actually
what the red is I thought this was soil
but it's actually salt
a planet with an abandoned rebel base
called crate I know a lot of people are
like wait you mean like crate dragon no
it's spelled with a C but it does remind
you of crate dragon
these are confirmed as gorilla walkers
they're basically walkers that the first
order found a way to prevent Luke's
speeder from taking them down if you
remember their legs were always very
vulnerable so they found a way to beef
up the front legs so that didn't happen
anymore but it also causes them to look
kind of like gorillas so that's why
they're being called gorilla walkers
what a coincidence that this whole scene
is a reference to the Battle of Hoth but
if you're a really big Star Wars ships
geek we found out that these frigates
are actually the Starhawk class frigates
from the aftermath series they talked
about the resistance having a new class
of starship that's what these are we
haven't actually seen pictures of them
before so I know there's not a whole lot
of kylo Ren in the trailer this is
mostly Rey Luke in the idea of the
Will's the idea of balance the true
nature of the force but what will
probably happen in the next trailer is
we'll get a more complete picture of the
story and we'll see what kylo Ren is
doing specifically because there's
training that he has to complete we have
to learn about his interest in the
Journal of the Wills and we have to
learn more about what's going on with
Finn and Poe's character we saw a whole
lot of Poe in the trailer but not a
whole lot of Finn probably because a lot
of his scenes take place on the planet
where Benicio del Toro is supposed to
show up there's another new planet and
it doesn't look like traditional Star
Wars so maybe they kept it out because
they thought it would have looked really
weird with all this other footage and
just taking people completely out of it
so what I'm expecting is is the next
trailer will just fill in a lot of the
other characters that you haven't seen
in this trailer so a lot more Finn maybe
some snow but definitely more kylo Ren
more phasma they marketed the hell out
of Basma last year even though she was
such a small part of the film but they
did say that that would be corrected a
grave error that they would correct in
this movie so way more phasma because it
looks like she was a huge part of
destroying luke's jedi academy but let
me know what other Easter eggs did you
guys spot on the trailer there's
probably even more that we'll find in
the next couple weeks but what I'm
expecting is is that may the fourth Star
Wars day will be the next time they
release new last Jedi stuff so that
could be anything that could be behind
the scenes stuff that could be a new
trailer I'm not expecting
full big trailer for a while so more
likely it'll be behind the scenes stuff
but if you didn't know there's a new
round of the rogue one blu-ray giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video if you already a
subscriber you just have to leave a
comment it's really simple but
congratulations to the winner from my
last trailer video Darryl Lawrence
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
announce the winner when I post my rebel
season 4 trailer video they're supposed
to show off footage but I'll be posting
updates on when videos are coming in the
next couple days and leave all your
requests for Star Wars bonus videos
while you wait for that to post you can
click here for brand new Thor Ragnarok
and you can click here to rewatch the
trailer again thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video